let us now illustrate with an example
all the calculations of n step
transition probabilities that we have
just discussed in this example we are
given a two-state Markov chain and as
part of the input the one step
transition probabilities between these
two states so given that you are in
state 1 the probability that you will
next go to step 2 is 0.5 and the
priority that you will stay in state 1
is 0.5 and given that you are in state 2
the priority that you will next go to
state 1 is 0.2 and the priority that you
will stay in state 2 is 0.8 now suppose
that you start in state 1 and you would
like to calculate the probability of
being in state 1 after n transitions or
after n steps with our notation here
this is our 1 1 of n that probability
can happen in two ways after n minus 1
steps you end up in state 1
and then for the last transition you
stay in state one or after the first n
minus one transition you end up in state
two and then you transition back to
state 1 assuming that you start again in
state 1 and you would like to calculate
the probability that you end up in state
2 after n steps you could apply the same
logic but these are probabilities and
given that you started in state 1 after
n steps you will either be in state 1 or
in state 2 so our 1/2 of n is simply 1
minus r1 1 of n and this system of two
equations is enough to propagate r1 1 of
n and r1 2 of n as a function of n let
us do it and fill the blanks here as
indicated before the case for N equals 0
or N equals 1 are simple and do not
require the use of the recursions here
so for example for N equals 0 r1 1 of 0
will simply be 1 and so as a result r1 2
of 0 will be 0 and again our - 2 of 0
will be 1 and as a result our - 1 of 0
will be 0 for N equals 1 these are the
simple one-step transition probabilities
so you have 0.5 here and 0.5 here and
our - 1 here our 0.2
and 0.8 the next case is for N equals
two becomes more interesting so to reach
N equals to R one one of two two options
again go this way where the property is
0.5 or you can go from that to here with
the priority 0.2 so here we obtain it
all pubs you 0.25 here probability of
zero point ten and when you sum these
two probabilities you obtain 0.35 which
is our one one of two and as a result
you get 0.65 for our 1/2 of 2 then you
can follow the same process for N equals
3 and equals 4 X cetera et cetera I will
not do it here but this would be an
interesting exercise for you to do the
next several steps perhaps within an
Excel spreadsheet but you pose that I
tell you with the number for N equals
100 and I tell you that the number that
you obtain here is about 2 over 7 so as
a result the numbers that you are going
to have here is about 5 over 7
let us then apply the simple recursion
in order to find the values here for N
equals 100 1 R 1 1 of 101 will be 2 over
7 times 0.5
plus five over seven times you point you
will be one over seven for the first one
plus one over seven for the second one
and so we obtain again 2 over 7
and if you do the same calculation you
will end up with five over seven here
this is an interesting fact when the
system starts in state 1 the probability
that I found myself in state 1 at the
long period of time seems to converge to
a constant value in that case to the
constant value of 2 over 7 assume now
that you want to do the same calculation
for R 2 1 and R 2 - in other words you
start in state 2 and you're interested
in knowing and the evolution of these R
2 1 of N and R 2 2 of n as a function of
n again I will let you do it but I can
tell you that these probabilities will
also seem to converge to a constant and
in fact will converge to something that
is exactly the same 2 over 7 here and 5
over 7 here this is a second interesting
fact irrespective of where we started
either from state 1 or from state 2 the
probability of being in a state 1 after
a long period of time seems to converge
to the same constant 2 over 7
so in some sense for that particular
example the importance of the initial
state vanishes as time goes by and does
not influence long term probabilities of
being in any of the two states note that
this is not true at the beginning
starting at state 2 the picture after
few transitions will look different than
if you had started from state 1 so the
initial state does tell you something at
the beginning but this vanishes as time
goes by we describe this convergence
properties by saying that the Markov
chain eventually enters a steady state
what does this really mean does it mean
that the state of the Markov chain
itself becomes steady and eventually
stops at a given place no the state of
the system will keep jumping forever
what becomes steady are the
probabilities that describe xn after the
Markov chain enters steady state then at
any time if you take a photo of the
system and ask what is the probability
that the chain will be in state 1 on
that picture it will be 2 over 7 by the
way the steady state of being in state 2
is greater than the steady state of
being in state 1 does it make sense yes
state 2 is a little bit more sticky than
state 1 in the following sense
when you get to state 2 the probability
that you remain in state 2 is 0.8 is
greater than the corresponding
probability for state 1 which is 0.5 so
to conclude this Markov chain has
exhibited some nice long term properties
is this always the case for any Markov
chains baracy